les gens du village entendent bien les
cris et les coups de feu des voisins
mais ils ne bougent pas bien au
contraire ils ferment les volets ils
ferment les portes ils se terrent ils
ont peur ils ont peur de quoi du
loupgarou la vie secrète d'une région
tire sa
survivance de la mythologie régionale de
ces légendes de ces coutumes de cette
littérature orale de ses histoires qu'on
se raconta Jadice au coin du feu et de
ces histoires qu'on se raconte encore
aujourd'hui de moins en moins hélas de
ces histoires qui parlaient des
chroniques villageoises de ces histoires
qu'on se raconaient au coin du feu dans
l'âtre et aussi sur les places de marché
les complaintes lesécolepteurs qui
venaient les chanter en montrant des
images toutes ces histoires criminelles
des histoires étrange quelquefois
fantastique quelquefois macabre foit
Surineur et aujourd'hui nous allons vous
conter une histoire tirée du Maré pois
de vin des brumes mystérieuses du Maré
pois de vin une histoire vraie
authentique une histoire où l'on croyait
encore au sortilège du
loupgarou écoutez braves gens l'histoire
épouvantable venue de nos
marais pour bouleverser nos âmes cette
histoire est réelle je vais vous
laacter c'est sûr de pauvres gens que le
sort s'est
jeté prenez garde de la nuit les ombres
cachent des tourments les brumes
poussées par le vent changent le destin
de la vie cette histoire s'est passée au
siècle dernier à l'époque où les
superstitions à les bon train les
habitants d'un petit village du Maré
poisevin avait des raisons d'être
inquiet effectivement toutes les nuits
une ombre se faufilait se profilait
devant la Lune rôé autour des fermes
quétait cet ombre quétait ce personnage
extraordinaire du commun fantastique les
gens avaient peur les plus malins le
guettai mais toujours il
s'échappait le lendemain tel ou tel
paysan trouvé son poulailler visité sa
cave ouverte sa grange fracturée et la
colère monté en même temps que la
[Musique]
crainte affolé par C ton on imagine tout
et le voleur de poule devient vite
Lougarou chacun ferme ses portes ses
volets puiss TER quand le village éteint
on perçoit des
[Musique]
Brières prenez garde la nuit les ombres
cachent des tourments les brumes
poussées par le vent changent le destin
de la
vie une nuit madame girudau est
réveillée par des hurlements son chien
ne cesse d'aboyer et tire sur sa
[Musique]
chaîne les gens du village entendent
bien les cris et les coups de feu des
voisins mais ils ne bougent pas bien au
contraire ils ferment les il ferme les
portes ils se terrent ils ont peur ils
ont peur de quoi du loup-garou qu'est-ce
que c'est un loup-garou justement on ne
sait pas trop et c'est ça qui
estffrayant c'est un personnage mihomme
mi bête il sort la nuit à la pleine lune
il vous Gatete dans le fossé il vous
saute sur les épaules il vous oblige à
courir longtemps jusqu'au temps où vous
tombiez par terre mort épuisé ou alors
il vous griffe ou alors il vous mort un
loupgarou ça court pendant 7 ans pendant
7 ans ça porte la peau de loup que ça
cage dans un creux de sa et quelquefois
un paysan en trouve une et là qu'est-ce
qu'il fait il la brûle et brusquement
arrive du village un homme un voisin un
cousin un frère un parent qui arrive
couvert de pustule couverur de brûlure
c'est lui le loup-garou et là on le
blesse d'une lame qui n'a jamais servi
et on le guérit il y a encore un autre
antidote contre le loupgarou on lui
jette entre les dents un bout d'étoffe
un châle un tablier un foulard n'importe
quoi mais il est condamné ce loupgarou a
déchiré le morceau d'étoff fibre par
fibre et là vous avez le temps de vous
sauver il y a encore un autre moyen
définitif c'est de lui placer dans le
cœur une balle
[Musique]
d'argent
d'étrange c'est réellement à Lougarou
car s'il s'est volatilisé ça sent le
souffre et là le père et la famille
Trabo
[Musique]
interviennent en vain ils ont cherché et
ne l'ont point trouvé les villageois
inquiets de peur
abandonné sauf un homme courageux releva
le
défi pour chasser du village ce mauvais
esprit prenez garde la nuit les ombres
cachent des tourments les brumes
poussées par le vent changent le destin
de la
[Musique]
vie
après la batue infructueuse le père qui
est un bon chasseur qui a fait la guerre
et qui connaît surtout bien la région
décide de faire sa propre chasse il fait
fondre le crucifi de famille et fabrique
la balle d'argent
[Musique]
la battue fut longue et difficile un
jour une nuit puis un jour encore enfin
le soir du deè
[Musique]
jour
cétait en fait un malheureux vagabond
que le chasseur venait d'abattre
néanmoins avant de mourir le soi-disant
loupgarou avait eu le temps de le
maudire de lui jeter un sœur à sa
famille et à
[Musique]
lui il mourut dans la nuit des suites de
une fièvre mystérieuse il eut juste le
temps de mettre ses fils en garde sur le
sort qui avait été jeté sur la
[Rires]
[Musique]
famille
comme le veut la coutume le fils aîné
prit la place du père et devint le chef
de famille mais cela ne dura
guerre il mourut le lendemain du même
mal
[Musique]
mystérieux
son frère le rejoignit dans la mort 2
jours plus
tard alors elle décida de tout vendre et
se prépara à partir en portant ce qui
lui était le plus cher les objets qui
lui rappelleraiit ce qu'il avait
quitté
[Musique]
c'est en fait en essuyant les bottes une
dernière fois les bottes qu'avaient
porté le père et ensuite les deux fils
que la mère découvrit le poteau rose le
secret du
mystère au fond elle découvrit deux
crochets deux crochets des dents de
vipère gorgé de venin et c'était ce
venin qui avait tuer d'abord le père et
ensuite les deux fils c'était ça la
malédiction du
[Musique]
Lougarou c'est ainsi que finit
l'histoire
épouvantable d'un père et ses deux fils
de leur fin
misérable la vie père du Maré devenue
sortilège aurait pu prendre le loup à
son propre
piège prenez garde la nuit les ombres
cachent des tourments les brumes
poussées par le vent changent le destin
de la
vie prenez garde la nuit les ombres cach
des tourmand les brumes poussées par le
vent changeent le destin de la
[Musique]
vie
I